this video is sponsored by
blinkist we all like to think we are
good at certain things above average in
certain areas most of us are at some
things but the truth is you are likely
wrong about how good or bad you are at
many things it is likely that you both
over and underestimate your actual
abilities in numerous areas of life and
the areas and the degree to which you're
wrong would probably surprise
you in a 1999 study psychologists David
Dunning and Justin Krueger discovered a
phenomenon that would be coined the
Dunning Krueger effect after giving
participants of the study various tests
that assess their abilities in humor
logical reasoning and grammar the
participants were then asked to self
assess their performance in relation to
their peers in the study Dunning and
Krueger found that people who perform
poorly on the tests tended to believe
that they did far better than they
actually did while those who performed
well tended to misperceive their
performance in relation to the average
of their peers in other words the study
would discover the cognitive bias where
people who are less knowledgeable or
experienced in an area tend to believe
that they are much more competent in
that area than they actually are and
those who are experienced and
knowledgeable in an area tend to
underestimate or doubt their abilities
these cognitive biases are the Dunning
Krueger effect although the phenomenon
is debated amongst researchers and on
the surface the effect may seem
paradoxical and bizarre arguably the
cause is
understandable if someone know knows
little about a subject or has little
experience in a particular area they do
not have enough experience or knowledge
to recognize the degree of their
incompetence in other words they don't
know enough to know what they do not
know if you're incompetent you can't
know you're incompetent the skills you
need to produce a right answer are
exactly the skills you need to recognize
what a right answer is said Dunning on
the flip side people with more knowledge
and experience in an area are aware of
the complexity vastness and difficulty
involved in being right or successful
and thus they are likely to be more
doubtful of their abilities they also
tend to think that others are more
capable in the area than what is
actually the case and so they are also
more likely to underestimate themselves
when ranked against others examples of
the dun and Krueger effect demonstrated
in studies include things like driving
where Studies have shown that 93% of
American drivers believe they are better
than average the phenomenon is also
often present in the workplace where
employees of companies tend to
overestimate their performance compared
to their co-workers were as many as more
than 40% of a company's employees
believe that they are in the top 5% of
performers of course everyone can't be
better than most there must be a
most throughout the processes of
learning strategizing evaluating and
reflecting there is another process at
play referred to as metacognition
metacognition is the awareness of One's
Own thought processes it's one's
thoughts about thinking a major part of
the learning process and a major factor
in being competent in something is the
ability through metacognition to
recognize patterns errors and problems
in one's thinking and then employ
strategies to deal with and overcome
them according to Dunning and Krueger
when someone is incompetent in an area
they lack metacognitive abilities in
that area as a result this lack of
awareness of their thought processes and
knowledge prevents them from recognizing
where and when they may go wrong and so
in their mind they never
do phenomenon can be fairly unsettling
on the individual scale to know that you
don't know what you don't know of course
you already knew that but the degree to
which you're unaware and the areas that
you might have such oversights where you
might otherwise feel pretty confident
can be disconcerting but it's even more
unsettling when considered on the
collective societal scale what's Curious
is that in many cases incompetence does
not leave people disoriented perplexed
or cautious instead the incompetent are
often blessed with an inappropriate
confidence idence booed by something
that feels to them like knowledge said
Dunning partly as a result of the
Dunning Krueger effect people who are
not qualified to speak on certain
subjects are still some of the most
confident and loudest who do more
qualified individuals rather tend to be
less loud and less simplistic and
instead more thoughtful and cautious and
for exceptionally high level experts
since they tend to misperceive how big
of a gap there is between them and the
average person it can be reasonably
assumed that they are likely to
insufficiently communicate about the
subject they are an expert in with the
general audience and of course in some
cases complex things simply cannot be
fully explained quickly or in
comprehensive terms to individuals who
are not experts themselves and so out of
the lot here the incompetent but
confident amature the competent but
cautious intermediate or the
exceptionally competent expert who is
confident but struggles to understand
and communicate with the Layon who is
more convincing to a mass audience of
individuals who do not know the
difference between correct and false
information it seemingly become more and
more common to have an opinion about
nearly everything maybe it's always been
this way maybe having access to all the
world's information but only enough time
to read the headlines and the incentive
to still leave a comment has exacerbated
this human tendency whatever the case
because of this and in combination with
the dun and Krueger effect some of the
voices we hear the most of are the least
qualified useful or accurate they are
rather voices of conf idence and
Charisma not nuance and Care the right
voices rather are often quieter harder
to parse or still looking for the right
words and means to express themselves
it's natural to want to have a voice
that is heard it's desirable to be
perceived liked followed impactful being
a voice of change and impact is a noble
goal but sometimes the greatest impact
is silence does the world really need
more voices or does the world need more
careful voices
of course the irony here being a voice
that is not silent is not lost but the
point here is not merely about being
silent outright it is about being
carefully noisy at least attempting to
be it's impossible to have no opinions
but it is possible to have less or be
more careful around how we hold the ones
we
do once you know about the dun and
Krueger effect it might feel like now
you are no longer susceptible to it or
perhaps you might feel as though it's
something you never were susceptible to
too you're not the kind of person who
overestimates their abilities you're
cautious and thoughtful and self-aware
you never make claims about things you
don't know you know your blind spots but
of course that's not how blind spots
work in truth do you think anyone who is
subject to the dun and crueger effect
overestimating their abilities or
knowledge thinks they are the phenomenon
is precisely that one does not know that
they are a victim to it the first rule
of the dun and Krueger club is that you
don't know you're a member of the dun
and Krueger club
said Dunning in fact thinking you're
impervious to the Dunning Krueger effect
is itself an example of the Dunning
Krueger effect you know just enough
about the phenomenon to believe you can
circumvent it while not knowing enough
to know you probably can't at least not
automatically or
universally perhaps however we can
overcome it more often with a certain
kind of awareness and
attitude by more regularly being silent
by being willing to be a nobody to let
our voice our presence our exist
distance not always be involved we can
perhaps be a victim of the effect less
and be on the right side of the effect
more in truth the average person is well
read and experienced in a relatively
small quantity of things at best we
don't need to be in more than that we
shouldn't try or pretend to be after a
certain point the quantity of opinions
one holds is almost always inversely
proportional to the quality and accuracy
of them we will inevitably often fail at
correctly making the distinction for
ourselves and knowing which areas we
belong in and which of our opinions
deserve sharing but that's okay the goal
here is simply to try our best
ultimately the Dunning Krueger effect is
a continual sliding scale that follows
us through life as long as we take on
new Endeavors new challenges new goals
we will be incompetent in certain areas
and as long as we are incompetent we'll
be partially ignorant to the true degree
of our incompetence but as long as we
continue to learn and grow we will also
uncover new knowledge and we will will
continue to realign our self-perception
with our actual abilities life is a
continuous cycle of realizing how little
you knew how much you were wrong and how
complex things really are and then
realizing it
[Music]
again this video was sponsored by
blinkist our awareness of ourself is
limited distorted and often confusing
our biases and oversights have tangible
impact on our lives lives they
disconnect us from reality and paint our
decisions in colors we are partly blind
to the books Thinking Fast and Slow by
Daniel conoman you're about to make a
terrible mistake by Olivier saboni and
know thyself by Steven Fleming all
provide highly unique and Powerful
insights into the nature of how we think
how we can often misunderstand our
thoughts and feelings how we can become
misaligned from truth and how we can
gain back better control of our thought
processes and make better decisions
using the app blinkist you can learn
from all of these books as well as over
6,600 other non-fiction books and
podcasts in just 15 minutes each of
course the more we learn the more
powerful and fine-tuned our radar
becomes for understanding the nuances of
things whether it's in ourselves the
world or the intersection of the two
where our decisions and evaluations
change everything with it being the
beginning of the new year blinkist is
the perfect way to broaden your
perspective and experience those
essential aha moments more often and
with blinket spaces you can easily
organize and share titles with those
close to you making it even easier to
build knowledge through a network of
people interested in the same things as
you whether it's a topic or a group of
people you can create a space around it
and share the books and ideas you
discover get 25% off blinket annual
premium membership and a 7-Day free
trial by using the link in the
description and of course as always
thank you so much for watching in
general and see you next
[Music]
video